hey everyone it's chef JJ I'm here today
hosting my annual potluck party with my
sous chef
Google's new smart display the Google
home hey Google cook with tasty welcome
back to tasty what would you like to
make today
JJ's holiday seafood pot sure here you
go did this look good it looks amazing
the inspiration is recipe came from my
time that I spent in Ghana I would go
fishing in the morning get this dry is
he food pot off the side of the street
and kind of drink out of a coffee cup I
brought it home and kind of put the JJ
Blair on it I loved this dish for the
holidays because it's like a big pot in
the middle of the table and all your
family or friends are jumping in
fighting over the king crab legs or the
biggest piece of shrimp it's just that
kind of moment that brings family
together so who's gonna wait for this to
come to a hard simmer and I'm gonna
throw in the clams and the mussels oh
yeah it's that time of year I'm gonna
have my crab legs everybody loves a good
crab way I love shrimp to be nice and
caramel and golden brown so I cook it in
the cast-iron pan and add it up Hagel
will show me my holiday photos showing
your photos for my family in the holiday
season my grandfather is 94 years old so
having him through the holidays is
really big for us
he is a major puzzle piece to the family
always reminiscing about who we were as
kids and what we did some people are at
the front door that's the doorbell
family and friends are here have an
amazing holiday
[Music]
so with the lemon juice for my ashram
[Music]